τη ίναι οποία να έχουμια κοντρατών το πράγμα όμως δεν είναιδεν σημαίνει ότι επιράζεις ο
κόμπα προσωγού κάμνουμε το λείον πουτσον πολίστηκα νανα νιώθουμε ότι μπορεί να μας επηρνανώκαι τα
μέσα καικαι ο τρόπο με τον οποίο δημοσιοποιείταιτ το πρά να να φαίνεται ότι επιράζουν
το κόμανομίζωμε το πιρζουν σου λέω εγώ που τη θέσημου βλέπο κόσμο να ακενάνα έρκεται
μέσα να θέλεια βοηθήσει σε απόψεις σε θέσεις σσσσε προτάσεις πολιτικές στο πρόγραμμα του κόματος
για τες επόμενο μέα σγια τον επόμενο χρόνο και τα λιπάν πάμε καιοπολιτικά κιόλοι κατάσταση
πως διαμορφών είνα τελευταίακ στητράορα νι τισεάν ισέχει περισότραμιλά ι το σενά το καγό σενάρι
το γαγόσις ναθυσιά μου υπάρχουν τρια συνάριο ποκλιμάκωσι που θάμε που είμαστε το οποίωμα από
μακρί είναιδ κάθεκάθει κτ γώρα έμβασε να μερικάνω νααπόμακρί να θερωναι κααπολέ η παρέμβαση η
παρέμβαση ομερικάνών προσπαθεί αποκλιμακώσει ιρητορική τουραχιστο ριτοριτού και βλεπά τον ρούπιο σήμερο καταρχίνει ίδια ϊδήλωση
το η ίδια η ενέργεια στέλθ καμέσα έριξακάποιες κάποιαςδόμες βόμβες υκαίνο ενκαμοτίποτε άλλο τελειώννοςγια το
μήνυμα λέοντας κάμαμε τελειώσαμε ατε πάμε για ειρήνι τορούπιο ότι είναι πόμεεη μέρα τον υπουργών
εξωτερικών της αμερικής να λέει ότι είμαστεν έτοιμη να συζητήσουμε είμαστε τοιμεα κάσον κάτο και
τα λιπ κια το λπά βλέπω ότι είμαστε στο μεσέίωσες να λατατι είμαστε στο σενάριος
το οποίον υπάρχει συραξει υπάρχουν αυτά που έχουν γίνει δεν θα σχολιάσω να καλώς έγινα
κακός έγινα δεν είναιναι ενοπαδικών των ζήτημαμε τώρα έχουμε πραγματαικές επιδράσεις που μπορεί να έρτου